when when you look at you know
the emerging forces in society that are
tearing it apart
what are the biggest ones to you in your
mind
well certainly ideological possession
plays a
huge role and i suppose to some degree
that's probably misplaced
spirituality it's something like that
and
and so i've i've always been struck by
nietzsche and dostoevsky's analysis of
the pathology of the west you know that
we're still suffering the cataclysmic
consequences of losing our
religious grounding you need some
conceptual scheme at the highest level
of
philosophical generalization you need
some way of answering
what is good and what is evil and some
way of answering what's the purpose of
my life and
maybe what's the purpose of existence
and at that level of analysis
the only answers are religious now you
can debate the rational acceptability of
those answers but that doesn't matter
i'm talking about the level of analysis
problem essentially if you're talking
about such things you're in the
religious domain
well intact cultures let's say or
traditional cultures have a structure of
ritual and myth and dance and music and
art
and story that
frames that uppermost domain of
conceptualization
and people live within that when it's
fragmented and shattered as ours has
been people turn to substitutes and
and those substitutes have all too
frequently been
well either a cataclysmic loss of faith
in existence itself which is
a nihilism that has terrible
psychological and social consequences or
the elevation of an ideological position
to the status of a religious belief
and that's not good and and so
everything in its proper place you know
you render unto caesar what is caesar's
and unto god what is god's
and you know the rationalist objector
will say well there's nothing that's
god's
and i would respond to that
by saying be careful what you presume
right because something has to act there
something has to exist there and you
fall into a religious story so
if if with the critique you laid out for
example of social institutions you say
well they tend towards corruption
and maybe they're so corrupt that only a
fool would have faith in them
and that's a powerful argument but it's
essentially a religious argument what it
does
is it it takes the problem of evil so it
it assumes that there's evil which is
the corruption and the power
maybe you don't use the term evil but it
doesn't matter it's still what you're
referring to
and then it places it in social
institutions says the problem of evil is
located
in the social institution well that's a
religious claim
it's also a faulty religious claim and
it'll twist you up and bend you around
because it's
it's incomplete and i tried to detail
that to a large degree in chapter 11
when i talked about
because you can think you can find
malevolence in your own soul you can
find malevolence in
other individuals you can find it in the
social order and you can find something
that looks like malevolence or certainly
feels like it in the natural world
right and if you only focus on one of
those then
well it's very convenient for you i mean
so one of the things i always
wonder for example if you locate evil in
the social world let's say in the
institutional world in the patriarchal
tyranny
well then you found an enemy right then
you found a target for all of your
unexamined spite and
resentment and cruelty and and homicidal
tendencies
all of that it's very dangerous
and this more sophisticated observers
and i think you can
make this case merely as a consequence
of observing literature as more
sophisticated observers place the battle
between good and evil inside the human
soul
and and then it manifests itself in
social institutions as well but
that's not the primary locale of the
divine battle
right christopher hitchens the late
great you know
writer um had had argued you know in a
polemic god is not great that
religion should be replaced by the canon
of literature
that uh the theology should be thrown
away and replaced with literature that
all of our great lessons
uh that we need to know are in
literature do you find
fault with that well the deepest
literature is religious
okay i mean that's what hitchens didn't
realize is that
if you if you took a hundred great books
and sifted them so that you derived
one great greatest book from it
then you'd have a religious text right
and and
and it would deal with these high order
concerns that we just described and
some of that can't be done rationally
which is partly why hitchens would
locate it in literature but it's not
just literature it's also
it's also located and expressed in
architecture
you know a cathedral says something
about the structure of being
now what it says you can't exactly say
that's why there's a cathedral instead
of the description of a cathedral right
it's the same with music and and perhaps
particularly religious music but
secular music is religious music it's
just been secularized it still has the
same
it still has the same impact and the
same religions seem to be less
relevant to uh people because a lot of
not all of their not all of their uh
lessons and morals which many of them
are great
but a lot of them uh the big three let's
take which you have uh christianity
judaism in islam
um christianity went through a pretty
serious reformation
um judaism is a small religion in terms
of the
numbers of people islam is going
maybe potentially going through a
reformation now in certain countries and
other you know
politically um so when people look at
these religions and we say the answers
are to be found there
there's sort of a deep skepticism
amongst a lot of people who look at
um you know when people were following
these religions to the letter of the law
and when they had an omnipresent uh uh
you know force in the political
structure of society
it was often quite an oppressive place
whether it was you know if you look at
like
the the catholic inquisition or whether
you look at you know modern day saudi
arabia for example
so there there's a skepticism about
those
belief systems being incredibly relevant
now
and then you arrive at this place where
people start believing in
you know that they're you know an other
can on tumblr or whatever nonsense that
you've
had to go up against for the last four
years she was like
what can you create or what can
we put in that because if people for
example if you were raised a
fundamentalist christian man you don't
feel for whatever reason that that
belief system
suits you uh anymore
and you you are out there
and you are looking for belief and
you're looking for meaning and you're
not you're not gonna find it and who
knows why that belief system doesn't
suit you i don't know it could be
your right your identity it doesn't work
it could be that your family and you
had something it could have been that
the particular church you were in was
uh abusive i know many catholics who
have left the church because of
the the litany of abuses right that has
happened
so what can we create or how do we
create
some type of and i'm not saying that we
we have to do it or it has to be a group
project i
loathe groups and i love your focus on
the individual in in that sense is what
makes you unique and interesting and the
individuals
george carlin had a great quote he goes
i love i hate people i love individuals
it was something to that degree
um but you know it i agree
wholeheartedly that the
what you see on the left right now is a
lot of people that are indoctrinating
themselves into a new religion
that is uh uh as oppressive
as unforgiving and as detrimental as a
lot of the tenets of old religion
but what can you do if you say um
you know i don't want to be a part of
that but i also don't want to be a part
of you know sort of that
you know archaic superstitious
kind of you know belief system that you
make well that's right
that's what we're all trying to work out
isn't it is what we should do i mean
i your your comments about hitchins are
very interesting to me because
i would say in the main i've taken his
word seriously right is that i do
believe that
the truth of the biblical truth for
example is a literary truth
it's not a scientific truth right
science isn't about morality it's about
something else
whatever the bible is about it's about
morality now you can
debate the moral lessons in the bible
but the bible is an extraordinarily
complicated book so it's not that clear
exactly what the lessons are let's say
but
having said all that i've adopted
a psychological slash literary approach
to
ethical truth and i've learned a lot
about
christianity for for example
as a consequence so and a lot of that
was from reading carl jung who wrote a
lot of what he wrote in response to
nietzsche's
observation that religion was dead that
god was dead yes yes
and so jung was influenced by freud but
at least as much by nietzsche and he was
trying to solve the problems that
nietzsche left
well you could
by definition christ is the perfect man
okay by definition right now you can
you can debate his representation in
christianity
that isn't what i mean i mean in some
sense i mean this
each of us has a relationship whether we
like it or not with the ideal
no matter how obscure and unarticulate
that
relationship is you know that because
your own
conscience will torture you and the
reason it tortures you is because you
fall short of your ideal it's there
in you now you have a responsibility
it's all it's pretty much the nature of
responsibility
to manifest yourself in accordance with
that ideal
there's no escape from that now what we
try to do collectively
is to represent that ideal and to come
to some agreement about what it is so
that we can organize ourselves
cooperatively and in productive peace
but there's no escaping from that
internal dialogue with the ideal
i mean every goal you have is a
reflection of that ideal
every aim you have every belief in
something worthwhile
all your conceptions that there is such
a thing as true truth or
your conceptions that there are good
ways of acting and evil ways of acting
all of that presupposes an implicit
ideal
part of what religious what our
religious structures have done
was focus on christianity is to try to
make that implicit ideal explicit
to represent it so that we can
understand it more and more deeply and
and so that we can also live
out its dictates let's say more
consciously
and we are we're always doing this
whether we know it or not so for example
you and i to the degree that we're able
to have this conversation
in a manner that is genuinely reflective
of
a a seeking of the truth
then we're manifesting a religious ideal
in the
context of the conversation and that's
why we're interested in it and that's
why other people are watching it
right and they don't have to know that
and they'll say that was meaningful
that struck me i i learned something uh
you know i thought i'd watch for five
minutes but i watched for an hour
right we can't help it this grips us so
for
for example you'll find yourself
respecting or disrespecting
people spontaneously you'll find
yourself in awe
of someone or not or contemptuous of
them
all of that means that you're in the
grip of a moral evaluation
that's related to this implicit ideal
and you know the more i've looked at the
representation of that implicit ideal in
religious
uh texts let's say but in the broader
religious culture the more i'm struck by
its profundity
so for for example i use this story
quite
frequently but the story of cain and
abel in genesis is very very short it's
only half a paragraph long it's very
very short
but it lays out very clearly the
dichotomy
of personality that exists inside the
human soul
there's part of us that part that's
represented by abel that
is striving towards the light that's
attempting to serve our own interests
and the interests of the broader
community and perhaps the divine
interest to the best of our
ability believing it
intrinsically in the in the basic
goodness of
existence and there's another part of us
that's rendered
cynical and bitter and murderous by
the tragedy of life and our sequential
catastrophic failures and inability to
put ourselves together
and cruelty of the world and that's
humanity where all of us are caught
between the
in the battle between those two opposing
viewpoints
it's religious to the core and we
when we lose christianity let's say we
lose thousands of years of the attempt
to make that
implicit reality explicit and
that's a catastrophe now we replace it
quite quickly we replace it with the
avengers universe you know where we
watch the battle between good and evil
being played out
in movies that cost hundreds of millions
of dollars to make and that push our
computational resources to the limit
think about that you know the most
sophisticated computational devices
on earth are used to generate artificial
realities where we can explore the
battle between good and evil
and then we line up and pay you know
inordinate amounts of money to expose
ourselves to this
and we find it gripping now we write it
off as entertainment
i don't write it off as entertainment i
take it seriously